[موسيقى]
مرحبا واضحى مبارك تابع عشاق الاثاره
الحربيه هذا الاسبوع واحده من اقصر حالات
التبرد العسكري حيث انقلبت الطباخ
بريجوجين على معلمه بوتين لساعات فتدخل
حليف بوتين ومريده كما يقال لوكاشينكو وحل
الازمه بدقائق فانسحبت ميليشياتو فاجنر من
مستولياتها الروسيه
ويدار ما دخلك شر ويا سجن ما دخلك شرير
الى العناوين
ر تتمرد وبوتين يتسامح حقنا لدماء الروس
وطائراتهم تقصف المدنيين في سوريا
البيت الابيض يستقبل بودي استقبال النجوم
والصحافه الامريكيه تصفه بمقوض
الديمقراطيه
الهلالي يدعو لاستبدال الاضاحي بالدجاج
والارانب ومفتي مصر يرد عليه
ابراهيم عيسى يطلب نقل المدارس الى
المساجد فهل هناك ما يمنع ذلك
يوسف زيدان يحرض من جديد على المسجد
الاقصى ويشتم صلاح الدين
رئيس سويسرا قرر اعتزال الرئاسه والتفرغ
لممارسه اليوغا
كشف الكرملين تفاصيل الصفط التي تمت بين
السلطات الروسيه ومجموعات ليفاجنر بواسطه
الرئيس بيلاروسيا لوقف الحرب وانسحابها من
المواقع الروسيه واعلن المتحدث باسم
الكريم
اسقاط دعوى الجنائيه ضد قائد مجموعه
فاجنرى مؤكدا انه لن تتم محاكمه عناصر
المجموعه المتورطين في التمرد وفق بيان
الكرملين احداث اليوم ماساويه يعتبر الذي
اعلن ان الاتفاق مع فاغنر حقنا للدماء
افضل ما في وقف التمرد هو حقل دماء
المدنيين الذين لا ناقه لهم ولا جمل في
حروب
الجيوسراتيجيات الدوليه هم في روسيا اناس
يعيشون حياتهم باحلام على مقاسهم ويريدون
ان يستمروا شانهم شان المواطنين السوريين
المدنيين الذين استهدفهم الطيران الحربي
الروسي في سوق شعبي
مواقع مدنيه بامتياز في جسر الشغور بادلب
بينما كان الكريم لن يسعى لحقن دماء
المدنيين الروس حمى الله جميع المدنيين من
خمسه ايام حتى الان هناك استهداف لمناطق
ماهوله بالسكان كما استفدت يعني منطقه كفر
نوران مناطق جبل زاويه منطقه اريحا منطقه
ادلب منطقه جسر الشغور كل هذه المناطق تم
استهدافها بشكل مباشر من قبل الطيران
الحربي الروسي هناك سقوط العديد من
الضحايا في هذه المناطق المدنيه كان جندي
اوكراني يلتهم بشراهه وسعاده وليمه من
الفساد او البوشار وهو يتابع اخبار التمرد
فاقدر وخطاب الوعيد الذي القاه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
رفضه صاحبه ميليشيات فاجنر بريجوجين الذي
اكد قبل ساعات قليله من انهائه التمرد انه
لن يستسلم ولا يخضع
مجموعه
توصف بانها شركه عسكريه خاصه ويراها اخرون
مجموعه عسكريه روسيه شبه رسميه وفق صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز تتمتع هذه الوحده
بالاستقلاليه وتتبع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
امر ينفيه الكرملان
صاحبها هو يفجين بريكوجين الملقب بطباخ
بوتين يعرف بادارته شركه كونكورد المنظمه
لحفلات الاستقبال بالكرملين تتكون فاجنر
من ميليشيات تقدم خدمات مقابل المال وماذا
تبيع فاجنر مقابل المال اكياس الجثث في
سوريا وليبيا والسودان واوكرانيا وغيرها
هل تقبض مالا عن كل انسان تقتله ام انه
بيع جمله هل هناك عروض واسعار خاصه على
قتل الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ كما حدث
ويحدث في سوريا هل القوانين الدوليه تسمح
بتاسيس بلاك ووتر وشركات قتل عابره
للقارات حدثونا عن الارهاب ما هي وصفته
الدوليه وهل تنطبق على شركات الموت هل ان
بعض التنظيمات المتطرفه التي تحمل عناوين
اسلاميه ما هي الا فروع المقنع لشركات
القتل هذه اسئله حفلت بها البواقع
والشاشات دون تحديد المرجع المسؤول عن
الاجابات وفق مسؤولين بريطانيين ارتفع عدد
مقاتليها من الف الى 20 الف مقاتل في
اوكرانيا تتهمو فاجنر بارسال مقاتلين الى
مناطق نزاعات مختلفه في سوريا انتشرت لدعم
النظام السوري منذ عام 2016 تنشط ايضا في
ليبيا لدعم القوات المواليه للواء
المتقاعد خليفه حفتر كما تنتشر في امريكا
اللاتينيه وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى وتشير
تقارير الى وجودها في مدغشقر وموزمبيق
والسودان ومالي
خدمته ظروفه بان تبوء عرش صناعه افلام
الاثاره والتسويق السينمائي
لانه لو قدر لملايين هواه التحليل الذين
جزموا في وسائل التواصل بان تمرد بريجوجين
تمثيليه من اخراج بوتين لسبقوا هيتشكوك
باصوات فرقه الزقيفه المصفقين التي نجدها
دائما في الشرق الاوسط موجوده ايضا في
روسيا
شبيحه مدينه روستوب هتفو لمقاتلي فاجنر
امام المقر العسكري النظامي الذي احتلوه
في الخلاصه
ليس حميتي وبوتين ليس البرهان ولا يجتمعوا
في دوله جيشان
نزلوا ليشاهدوا حطام سفينه تايتنك ولم
يعلموا ان رفاتهم سيستقروا الى جانب
الحطام وبعد ان كانوا سياحا اصبحوا الان
المكان السياحي بحد ذاته تيتان وتايتنك
حرف واحد فقط يفصل بين الاسمين انتقد
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما
التفاوت الكبير بين قوه التغطيه الاخباريه
العالميه لغواصه الموت تيتان وعلمتها خمسه
اثرياء وضعف التغطيه لقارب الموت الذي غرق
الاسبوع الماضي امام اليونان وعلمته 750
طالب لجوء اوباما لم يبدي ارتياحه ايضا
لطريقه استقبال رئيس وزراء الهندرا مودي
في البيت الابيض
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز علقت على نفس الموضوع
بان ميركا استقبلت مودي كنجم متغاضيه عن
سجله في محاربه الاقليات
وتقويض الديمقراطيه حليف وصديق بلغه
المصالح والولاءات يحتضن البيت الابيض
نارين درامودي مره اخرى في زياره وصفت
بالتاريخيه والتي يجريها الى واشنطن رئيس
الوزراء الهندي يحظى مودي باهتمام وترحيب
كبيرين في الولايات المتحده رغم المخاوف
من انتهاكات محتمله لحقوق الانسان في
الهند وفي تلميح مبطن الى المخاوف في هذا
الصدد وصف بايدن الحريه الدينيه بانها
مبدا جوهري بالنسبه لبلاده وللهند على حد
سواء ليس في ثوب ديمقراطيه الهند وحرياتها
الابيض نقطه سوداء حسمها مودي وبالغ في
رده على سؤال صحفيه جريئه لكن المثل
الهندي يقول تؤخذ الطيور بقوائمها وتؤخذ
الرجال بالسنتها
احتفاء بخطابه في الكونجرس تشكل طابور من
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي للظفر بتوقيع
مود الثمين والتقاط صور التذكاريه معه
وخلال زيارته الرسميه للقاهره هذا الاسبوع
منح مودي قلاده النيل هذا وقد قام لرئيس
المصري بتقليد رئيس الوزراء الهندي بقياده
النيل التي تمثل ارفع الاوسمه المصريه
واعظمها شانا وقدرا ازدواجيه المعايير ليس
لها حدود في النظام العالمي الراهن ويصادف
ان المهملين من العداله الدوليه
متشابهون ثقافيا ليل الشيخلي تسال مقرر
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان بميانمار عن
الفوارق بين اللاجئين الاوكران واللاج من
الروهنئه فتبين من الاجابه ان البعيد عن
العين بعيد عن القلب
ساعدنا ان نفهم لماذا يبدو المجتمع الدولي
مترددا في تقديم مساعده حقيقيه للروهنديا
في وضع الصور مؤلمه جدا شاهدناها لسنوات
القصص كما اشرت الى بعض منها مؤلمه جدا
ولكن في نفس الوقت المجتمع الدولي هب
لمساعده مثلا اللاجئين الاوكرانيين ما
الذي يجعل قضيه اللاجئين الروهنجيا
متعسره ومتعذره على الحل لهذه الدرجه
هذا سؤال ممتاز جزء من هذا العالم مشغول
بازمات اخرى البعيد عن العين بعيد عن
العقل والقلب
بعض المتمسكين بعباره لقمه في فم جائع خير
من بناء الف جامع عندما انا اوان اطعام
الجائعين اللحوم في عيد الاضحى راحوا
يدعون الى وقف سنه الاضاحي او تغييرها
يقول سعد الدين الهلالي البهيمه ليست
ضروريه للاضحيه
فبالامكان استبدالها بالفراخ والارانب طب
ما ننشر ثقافه الاضحيه بالطيور اللي قال
عليها داود ابن علي الظاهري وابن حزم
الظاهري ورواه عن بلال بن ابي رباح
واستندوا لادله في القران والسنه
مش خروف حتى واتحدى حد يقول ان الاتباع
هذا الراي باطل الهلالي يتحدث فتواه هذا
مفتي مصر شوقي علام الذي يتهم بالتساهل
باصدار فتاوى تحت الطلب لم يتحمل كارثه
الهلالي وهكذا رد على سؤال حول فتواه
والبعض تزايد وقال ممكن تضحي بفرخه ممكن
تضحي بطه تضحي بوزه دخيل هذا النصوص
الشرعيه في القران الكريم وفي ممارسه
سيدنا رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بتدل
على اختصار الاضحيه على البهيمه الانعام
بهيمه الانعام بتشمل ثلاثه انواع بتشمل
الغنم تشمل البقر وبتشمل الابل الشيخ
الازهري ابراهيم رضا يعتبر فتوى الهلال
الشاذه بمثابه اعلان حرب على الدوله
المصريه
وتحقير لشعبها وقدرته على الحياه
ويسال هل سيفتي الهلال السنه الجايه
باستبدال اضاحي الحجاج بالاستاكوزا جراد
البحر
اللي عملت موائد الرحمن اكن المصريين دول
من يوم النبي مجالهم بالدعوه لغايه
النهارده
في عقلي ولا وعي ولا اتزان علشان مستنين
حد يطلع لنا ويقول لنا ان الاضحيه تجوز من
الطيور ومن الارانب ومن البط طب خلاص يبقى
الحجاج السنه الجايه ما يدبحوش الهادي
وصل ابراهيم عيسى ممارسه هوايته بالتسبب
بجدل دائم في مصر بعد اقتراحه بتحويل
المساجد دون غيرها الى مدارس لتعويض نقص
المباني التي تشكو منه وزاره التربيه
عندنا 150 الف جمع نحولهم مدارس من صلاه
الصبح بتخلص شوف امتى وتبدا الدراسه لغايه
صلاه العصر يعني يعني او الجوامع يعني
والناس الفسحه تبقى صلاه الظهر والفسحه
التانيه او المرواح مع صلاته في العصر
دفاعا عن ابراهيم عيسى الذي يصعب الدفاع
عنه لكن الرجل لم يقترح اغلاق المساجد بل
اضافه الدوري التعليميه ضمن حرمها فما
الدير في ذلك اذا تم ضمانه احترام اداب
بيوت الله بل سيشجع ذلك الطلاب على اداء
الصلوات في تركيا ومع بدء العطله الصيفيه
يفتح امام مسجد طوقات ابواب المسجد
للاطفال واهاليهم امام ممارسه نشاطات
رياضيه وترفيهيه
[موسيقى]
يوسف زيدان استاذ جامعي مصري اشتهر
بالتحريض على نصوص دينيه وبتزوير التاريخ
الاسلامي وسير عظماءه وتراث الازهر الشريف
احاله اتحاد كتاب مصر العام الماضي
للتحقيق بشبهه الترويج لالقائه محاضره في
تل ابيب كما ثبتت سرقته الادبيه لروايه
انجليزيه بحسب التقرير حتى يقال عنه كاتب
فقالوا عنه كاذب في عام 2009 فازت روايه
عزازيل بجائزه البوكر للروايه العربيه قبل
ان يكتشف الجمهور ان مؤلفها يوسف زيدان قد
سرق الكثير منها من روايه الانجليزيه نشرت
عام
للكاتب تشارلزلي بعنوان كيباتيا يوسف
زيدان جدد مؤخرا انكاره وجود المسجد
الاقصى المبارك في فلسطين وهو على يقين
بان هذه الفريه لا يصدقها احد فلمن يريد
ان يوصل صوته بالمسجد الاقصى المذكور في
تقول بانه يوجد حسب الروايه التاريخيه بين
مكه والمدينه اليس كذلك نحن عارفين ان
سيدنا محمد راح دعا في الطائف على طريق
مكه الطائف الطائف كان فيها كعبه الله
الكبرى في الجزيره العربيه وكانت منطقه
مقدسه يعني فكان الذهاب اليها بيبقى في
موضوع موضعان للسجود في بلد اسمها
الجعرانه والمسجد
الاقصى بناه يع
قوب حفيد ابراهيم
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ما سئل عن اول
بيت وضع للناس قال المسجد الحرام ومعلوم
المسجد الحرام انه ابراهيم قال ثم ماذا
قال المسجد الاقصى قال كم بينهما قال
اربعون سنه تخصص يوسف زيدان في التشكيك
بسيره فاتح القدس تحديدا فاتهم مرارا
بالاساءه الى الخليفه عمر بن الخطاب رضي
الله عنه فيما بلغ به الحقد على الناصر
صلاح الدين الايوبي ان وصفه باحقر
الشخصيات في التاريخ ليش شفت انه هو
الشخصيات التاريخيه انه شفتوا انه ما قال
بالسلطان بتاعه نور الدين محمود ومكره
الخليفه الفاطمي
وتعامل معاه برخص الشديد وبعدين قتل ابن
السلطان المسلم انما تقولي لي خلد هو خلد
في السينما في الفيلم بتاع جمال عبد
الناصر اللي صرف عليه ده عشان ده الناصر
صلاح الدين وده جمال عبد
كله اخطاء تاريخيه رايه زيدان لا يحتاج
الى راي اخر فالشتيمه ليست رايا بهيج ليس
استاذا جامعيا ومع ذلك لا يسمح لنفسه بان
يستخدم لغه زيدان في الشتم مع انها لا
تتطلب مهارات لكن الشتيمه تضعف الحجه يقول
معلق ويضيف بان الدفاع عن الحقيقه يكون
بالكلمه وبالحكمه وبلجوء المتضررين الى
القضاء فالاحترام لاهل الاحترام فقط اما
الامن فللجميع الصالح والطالح مشايخ
الازهر سئموا من الرد على الحالات
الزيدانيه فيكفي الازهر الشريف ان يتصدى
بالموقف للمستوطنين الاسرائيليين الذين
احرقوا المصاحف اثناء اعتدائهم على القرى
الفلسطينيه
حرمه مساجد تمزيق نسخ من القران الكريم
واحراقها سيارات محروقه نوافذ محطمه بيوت
تاكلها النيران هي بعض من مشاهد الاضرار
التي خلفها اعتداء المستوطنين على البلدات
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه بعد اعمال
الشغب واعمال الانتقام من قبل المستوطنين
في قريه ترشعيه من السهل رؤيه الاضرار
الكبيره التي لحقت بالقريه منازل وحقول
زراعيه وسيارات كلها اضرمت فيها النيران
حاجه مصريه قليله الحيله تترضى على
ابنائها البارين الذين ساعدوها ضمن
استطاعتهم على جمع تكاليف الحج على مدى 20
عاما ماضيه جمعتها جنيه حتى استطاعت الى
الحج سبيلا انا الحاجه سناء من مصر ان شاء
الله قعدت اكتر من 20 سنه اقدم في الحج
واجمع في فلوس الحج ولما ربنا اراد بقى لي
ولادي ساعدوني ويقدموني وطلعت في ورقه
الحجره
ما كنتش قادره استحمل فرحة من كتر الفرح
فيها يا رب يسعده
يا رب في اسبانيا توفيت موظفه في شركه
خاصه على كرسي العمل نتيجه ازمه قلبيه
حاده ومع ذلك استمر زملائها في العمل
بجانب جثتها وكان شيئا لم يكن فقد رفضت
الاداره طلب زملائها المقربين بمرافقه
الجثه الى المستشفى اما الباقون فلم
يكلفوا انفسهم عناء القاء النظره الاخيره
على المتوفاه انها دوره العمل والانتاج في
قيم الغرب المخي موظ
وزملائها يواصلون العمل بجانب جثتها كان
شيئا لم يحدث حادثه دنيئه في قلب مدريد
الاسبانيه حيث استمر موظف احدى شركات
الاتصال العامه لساعتين بجانب جثه زميلتهم
التي مرت امامهم بازمه قلبيه حتى توفيت
وحسب شهادات الحاضرين فان المقربين من
صدموا بالحادثه لكن طلبهم المغادره قد رفض
بينما السبعون موظفا الاخرين لم يكلفوا
انفسهم عناء رفع اعينهم عن اجهزه الحاسوب
حتى ان احدهم عندما سئل اذا كان على ما
يرام رد ببرود سانهي هذا واغادر الرئيس
السويسري الامم ابتدع بدعه يجب ان يحاسب
عليها في معهد كيم جونغ اون الافتراضي
لتابيد الحكام الاخ اعلن عن تقاعده من
السياسه والرئاسه يلي انتخبوا الشعب لالا
مع نهايه هذا
اما حجته التخريبيه فهي انه تقلد المناصب
الحكوميه للتي عشر عاما وهذه مده طويله
جدا وقد ان الاوان لكي امارس اليوغا يقول
هذا الرئيس المارق في الاعراف التابيديه
رائد الفضائل الاماراتي سلطان النيادي
يمارس اليوغا ايضا في الفضاء ويواصل رحلته
الاستكشافيه الفضائيه بنجاح فبعد ان عبر
من المركبه الفضائيه عن شوقه وافتقاده
لطبخ البيت وصله مؤخرا من كوكب الارض كيس
من التفاح المركبه اللي وصلت قبل اسبوع
جابت لنا اكل طازج وهذا هديه من الارض
تفاحه طازجه
ان شاء الله راح نستمتع فيها
وشارككم بعض الصور بالنسبه للحركه
بسويلكم فليب بحاول اني ما ادعم شي يا
سعود
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ختاما كتب محمد الماغوط عندما كنت اسمع
بائع الجرائد ينادي الوطن بثلاث ليرات
الثوره بليرتين العروبه بليره وربع والشعب
بليره كنت اظنه يقصد سعر الجرائد الى
اللقاء
تغير هوانا
وسعر كل شغلي غلي
وخسي زرعها كنت
ما عادت
ما عادت الي
ما عابد
[موسيقى]
ومش هم بعد اليوم
نبهدلني حدا
صارت حياتي كلها
شيبه هالدليل
اسمع
اسمع يا رضا
امشي عمي يغني لا ويزيد
ما راح كنا على
حديدي وهلا صرنا على حديد
[موسيقى]